in the title by uh daniel dennett
herding cast and the free will inflation
so um what does herding cats mean what
does free will inflation mean so this i
love this essay um because it explained
to me how i could live in a
deterministic universe
um but
have
not free will but have freedom you know
um
and beca and also it helped me explain
that
that time needed to be a real thing in
this universe so what basically dan was
saying here is like um how do you how do
these cats appear to just do what they
want
right
and how if you live in a deterministic
universe why do the cats do these things
you know aren't they just isn't it all
obvious
um and how does free will inflate the
universe and for me i mean probably i
love the essay because my interpretation
of the essay in assembly theory makes
complete sense
um because
you need an expanding universe in
assembly theory
to create novelty
that you search
for that then when you find something
interesting and you keep doing it
because it's cool and it gives you an
advantage
then it appears in the past to be a goal
so what what does in assembly theory the
expansion of the universe
look like
what are we what are we talking about
why is why
why does the expansion universe give you
more possibilities of novelty and cool
stuff
so for me i don't think about the
universe in terms of big bang in space i
think about in terms of the big the big
memory expansion that you have one you
only have the ability to store one bit
of information so you can't do very much
so what the universe has been doing
since the since forever it's been
creating more
it's been increasing the size of its ram
okay so like one megabyte two megabytes
three megabytes four megabytes all the
way up and so
the more ram you have
the more you can remember about the past
then which allows you to do cooler
things in the future so if you can
remember how to launch a rocket then you
might be able to imagine how to land a
rocket
and then relaunch re-land and carry on
because and so the the
you able you're able to expand the space
and remember the past and so that's why
i think it's very important but not a
perfect memory it's it's a it's an
interesting question whether there's
some forgetting that happens it might
increase
is the expansion of the
forgetting at some point accelerate
faster than the remembering i think that
that's a very important thing that
probably intelligence does and we're
going to learn in machine learning about
because you want machine learning right
now or artificial intelligence right now
doesn't have memory right but you want
the ability to or not for if you want to
get to human-like consciousness you need
to have the ability i suppose to
remember stuff and then to selectively
forget stuff so you can re-remember it
and compress it arguably the way that we
come up with new physical laws
yeah you like it that's that yeah sorry
you were confirmed no no that's right no
i just wanted it i i think that um
there is a a great deal to be gained
from having the ability to remember
things but then when you forget them you
can then have a you can basically do the
simulation again and work out if you get
to that compressed representation
so that it's in cycles so
cycles of memory remembering and
forgetting are probably important but
there shouldn't be excuse to have a
universe with no memory in it the
universe is going to remember that it
forgot but just not tell you
you